But they did not want to anger
fox viewers that never
happened.
>> Brian Todd reporting for, us
Brian, thank you so much.
Let's bring in our legal and
political experts.
As we learn more about Rupert
Murdoch's bombshell deposition,
just how strong is dominions
1.6 Dillion dollar --
>> I think it is strong.
The constitution protects
speech and we need that for the
press, but there are limits.
If you put on news when you
know it is false or you are
behaving recklessly, you can be
held rile --
liable and by admitting that
fox did not just report, they
endorsed, Rupert Murdoch has
helped dominion make its case
and it's not just 1.6 billion,
that is just the lost profits
and the enterprise value that
is lost.
That could be multiplied
several times over for punitive
damages.
That is a possibility.
>> Adam Kinzinger, do you as a
Republican who challenged all
those election lies, feel
vindicated by Murdoch's own
admissions?
>> I guess vindicated to an
extent.
But I am just even more
disappointed because I know
this is not going to affect
viewership a fox.
A lot of these people may be
new that they're being lied to,
but it made them feel good.
And you know, look, we as
Americans have got to sit back
and say, is there, a limit to
getting on television as an
authority and making a complete
and other lie that could and
did lead to violence.
Ashli Babbitt, who was killed
at the capitol, never would
have been there had these lies
not been --
the law enforcement officers
that were injured and those
that took their own lives, they
would not have had to engage in
that had those lies not gone
over and over.
The equivalent I've heard
people compare to win big
tobacco admitted secretly that
they knew this was killing
people, this is the equivalent
of that.
Eventually people will listen.
I hope it soon.
>> Maggie, as you, know this
raises serious questions about
foxes role as a media
organization, especially as the
next presidential election
approaches.
Do you think there will or
should be consequences in terms
of foxes journalistic access?
>> I think the range of what
consequences mean depend on who
is doing the evaluating here.
In the eyes of dominion, they
would like to see a lawsuit
settled in their favor, but
there is no, as you, know sort
of grandeur hand that can be
arbitrated --
to your question, in terms of
how it conducted itself, it is
not normal for a news outlet to
put out information that it
clearly believes to be false
and so even if they do want to
say these are opinions, that
will raise all kinds of
questions that this is now --
it sounds like another aspects
of this lawsuit --
it dominion folks have
information that fox officials
and Rupert Murdoch were
questioning --
more than questioning, did not
believe the veracity of this
information.
There is a bit in the suit that
said that --
but was going ahead with this
anyway and that will raise all
kinds of questions going
forward.
Will it change how fox operates?
Certainly not while this
lawsuit is going on because
that could become a problem in
their lawsuit.
But weather does after that,
remains to be seen.
>> Adam, let me turn to speaker
Kevin Mccarthy's decision to
give tucker Carlson early
access to the capitol security
footage.
He is releasing involving the
January 6 defendants.
Let's listen to the speakers
explanation.
Listen to this.
>> We are not concerned about
the fact that Carlson has
downplayed this attack --
you thought it was a serious
attack.
>> It is very serious.
I think sunshine matters.
I don't care what side of the
issue you are on, that is why I
think putting out --
you can see the truth.
See exactly what transpired
that day.
>> How can Mccarthy say this is
about transparency went so far
he is only giving access to
tucker Carlson and the January
6th defendants who have been
charged?
>> Look, Kevin Mccarthy is
doing the best he can to spend
--
spin's decision.
When he says I don't care what
side of the issue you are on,
you probably should care
because you're the speaker of
an institution that was
attacked.
You think it's sunshine to give
it --
it's even one thing if you give
it to Fox News writ large.
He gave it to tucker looked
Carlson, who within the last
year, put out a video basically
saying that the government did
this and all these riders are
heroes.
Kevin Mccarthy has confused me
probably more than anybody I've
known in my life.
He used to be somebody I
thought was very much committed
to what his truth was, what he
believed.
He is completely shed that for
power.
It's disturbing and frankly,
other news agencies ought to
have the exact same stuff that
he gave to tucker freaking
Carlson, who is the biggest
conspiracy theorist out there.
>> How will Mccarthy's decision
to give the accused rioters
access to this footage impact
the legal process here?
>> Well, it will enable the
lawyers for the accused rioters
to say --
to have a new source of
information.
They need more time, they
already have an warmest amount
of disinformation and I am
concerned about the security
aspects of both the tucker
Carlson and the other selective
releases of this.
There is a reason that some of
this footage has not been seen
before.
Because it reveal sensitive
security information about the
congress.
So, it is a bad decision, it
has legal implications and
ethical once.
I think it is wrong.
>> Maggie, what will the
political fallout before
Mccarthy's decision about this
footage?
>> I think it's too soon to say
because we don't know what's
going to be shown and what is
on their.
I grew the congressman that if
he was interested in sunshine,
he would just put this on a
website and then people get
evaluated for themselves.
It wouldn't be through a filter,
he --
it would just be out there.
I think it depends on what is
on it and what the reactions
are.
I think they're very few people
in this country who don't have
an opinion already of what took